bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you thank you for turning
into the D Shah and now do you know
anybody from Zimbabwe can you think
right now do you know anyone that you
know from Zimbabwe oh I know somebody
that's my next guest coming in all the
way from Zimbabwe that's right if you
guessed it right you do a guessing would
have been guessing Mufti mink here on D
show so don't go anywhere we have an
exciting show for you today right
and we're back here on the Dean show
with our special guest Mufti MEK here on
the dicho Sheikh how are you Salam
alaikum - LA - LA here but I can handle
it laughs now your your we got you all
the way from Zimbabwe is that right yes
that's correct mashallah how are things
down there I'll handle it the weather is
so beautiful mashallah I wish you could
come here inshallah and taste a little
bit of this weather maybe who knows in
the future give our salams to everybody
down there we're excited to have you on
the on the Deen show we're gonna get
right into it and we wanted to first
start off and get things get things
rolling with a billboard that we've seen
out there here in the states I don't
know if you've ever have seen it on
internet internet it says the Billboard
says God probably doesn't exist so stop
worrying and enjoy life so when people
see this you know some people obviously
you know they look at this as
foolishness but some people there you
know in this growing trend of pulling
away from from the Creator
you know people get confused so to get
them unconfessed we will not be able to
use Revelation in order to convince
people who are trying to understand what
the billboard is saying and looking into
it because Revelation is for those who
believe already and although it will
affect the disbelievers in a positive
way but to start off with they need to
be convinced from perhaps their minds
normally what I say is do you know the
mere fact that we only have
approximately 70 years in this world
already goes to prove that it is not
everlasting if it was really just to
enjoy it would have been much longer
than that because 70 years is nothing
and we keep on you know passing the
baton on to
next generation and passing subhanAllah
in a way that we age we become old of
late in the last few weeks I've been
saying in my talks that amazingly we
grow in the presence of our parents and
we become much more handsome and we
become good-looking and so on and then
you get married and guess what starts
happening you actually have your spouse
watching you become old and become frail
if you are given life so if it was all
about enjoying then surely we would have
been in a position where we could be
boasting off to our spouses saying you
know what as the days pass I'm going to
become stronger and bigger and better
and so on and more beautiful and
whatever but there is definitely a plan
and another thing is even from a logical
point of view if we take a look at what
you've just said on the billboard if a
person happens to believe that there is
a maker who has made if a person happens
to believe that or if a person believes
that there is nothing you know we are
going nowhere we just enjoy God perhaps
doesn't exist and so on and on the other
hand you have another person who
believes that God does exist if we take
a look at that from a purely
psychological or should I say from a
brain perspective just out of nature say
I am disciplined and I'm a person who
really believes that God does exist and
I do good deeds and so on and then I die
I believe that I'm going to a good place
now the person who did not do good deeds
at all for example and they just did as
they wish they believe that they're
going to return to the soil and perhaps
to nature and perhaps whatever else they
believe but what I do know for a fact is
that if I do what I do by being good and
by obeying the commands and instructions
of the Almighty and so on then I'm
losing nothing at all because from a
purely you know probabilities point of
view I will either be where he thinks
I'm going to be and and we would be in
the same place or I would be in a better
place but if he was actually correct
then if he was actually correct and I
would be either with him or I would be
in a better place
sadly what would happen is if I am
correct then he is doomed and and this
is what we say that it's best for us to
play it safe life is only once
definitely it's only once in the sense
that in this dunya it's once we do
believe in the life after death which is
a different everlasting life
but subhanAllah if you if you understand
that to risk this one life that you do
have in such a way that you when you die
you may have messed things up completely
is definitely not worth it so I would
rather convince a person who's looking
at this type of a billboard and tell
them look
you'd rather be disciplined because if
you are then inshallah you will be going
to a better place than to be a person
who just does as they please and is
risking everything they have is risking
the entire life after death which is far
far longer than this particular life and
that's definitely proven because those
who died and have been dead for longer
than we who are alive and when they were
alive - they were there for a very short
time compared to the amount of time that
they have been dead for so Allah knows
better
Sheikh tell us before we go to break
people can see the intellectual people
they see the contradictions and these
man-made religions so they put them all
in the same bucket
how can people be sure without a doubt
that Islam is not a religion made by a
man or group of men but it's indeed from
the Creator one simple way of looking at
things Islam is unique because it calls
to the worshipping of the one who made
you alone no one else so it is not
calling to the worship of muhammad
sallallahu alayhi wa sallam may peace be
upon him or jesus may peace be upon him
or Moses may peace be upon him or anyone
else but it is actually calling towards
the worship of the one who made you
alone no risk involved and this is why
we say when I put my head on the ground
in the five daily prayers I'm actually
putting it on the ground solely and only
for the one who made me the one who is
in charge or in absolute control of my
existence and the one whom I'm going to
return to so I am saying o you whom I am
going to return to you are the greatest
now when I die definitely I will get to
whoever it was and I'm where
this way you know for those who might
not be believing I'm going to get back
to whoever it was who I constantly said
oh you whom I'm going to return to and
then he will tell me well you worshiped
me and me alone and I would say well
it's only you whom I worshiped so this
is the uniqueness of the Dean of Islam
worshipping the Allah or the one the
maker the one who made you alone may
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala grant us all
guidance if you take a careful look at
this you will be convinced that what the
Muslims are actually preaching or
teaching or what they believe is
something that would result in no risk
at all when it comes to post death
because you have worshipped the one you
are going to return to anyway and you
have worshipped him and him alone and
this is where the yucca na'budu wa
iyyaka nastain comes in the verse of the
opening chapter of the quran you alone
we worship and you alone we ask for help
so I'd like to think that this would be
quite convincing by the will of Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala before we go to
break in the last minute that we have is
it true that Islam now is the same
religion the same way of life that was
practiced by Jesus peace be upon him
Moses Abraham the first man Adam is this
the same way of life that they all
practice that we're practicing today if
you look at it it's divided into two one
is the aspects of belief and the other
is the rules and regulations of that
which is permissible and prohibited in
the way of living so when it comes to
permissible and prohibited that can't
change and it does it has changed
somewhat you know through the years and
through these so when I say the years I
mean through the various prophets as
such now we have the finality of that
with muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam but when it comes to belief and
the pillars of belief they were exactly
the same identical ditto they're every
messenger call towards the worship of
the maker alone and you know the respect
of the messenger that belief in the
message itself the last day life after
death good and bad faith comes from the
Almighty and so on these are the pillars
of what we know as belief so that is
identical but when it comes to what we
call rules and regulations and the laws
of living and so on that would
change with the changing of the
messenger because of the changing of
times but we've got now to what we would
term the Sharia of Muhammad Allah lover
of allah subhanahu wa ala revealed
through muhammad sallallahu alayhi wa
sallam these laws are obviously you know
laws that may not be exactly identical
to what Jesus made peace be upon him
Cain will but the bulk of it is quite
similar alhamdulillah
oh the the worship of calling one to
worship the Creator not the creation the
one God that's all the same that note
we're gonna take a break shape and we
right back with more with Mufti Beck
here on the Deen show so called who
Allah say he allows one God is one the
maker of mankind exactly a lot of sunlit
lost self-sufficient he doesn't need
food or drink he doesn't need to rest on
the seventh day okay I really had a
problem with that even before I knew
anything about Islam God resting sounds
like a weak guy yeah lemme eyelid well
I'm you let he begets not he doesn't
have any children nor see a child or
born of anything or anyone
well then yeah Julio hope before I die
and there's nothing co-equal or
comparable to him at all nobody nothing
Jesus nobody nobody is comparable to the
Creator nothing yeah and that right
there was in his essence what I believe
naturally
you
and back here on the D show our special
guest all the way from Zimbabwe shaykh
Mufti mank so back to the topic at hand
and the Deen show really is trying to
reach out and clear up the negative
stereotypes and the false misconceptions
but when people really look at Islam we
see why it's the fastest growing way of
life in the world today yesterday and
tomorrow because it makes sense and you
just explained the concept of the crater
that we have a direct dial up with the
crater but now we are also trying to
reach out to those who are our brothers
in humanity who have leaned towards
worshipping one of the greatest
messengers that God ever sent who ate
slept pray to God some people worship
Jesus is God they call him God or son of
God
now you said an interesting story once
and it may be if you can reiterate it
here on the DS show of a young kid who
was kind of trapped between some
crocodiles if you recall and then he was
calling out to his maker can you go
ahead and let us let our viewers in on
this story and then the importance of of
putting Jesus in his right place and not
elevating him to God story I must say
with all due respect because we do have
this mutual respect that we do call for
as muslimeen you know it's important for
us to know that we do respect one
another as human beings and it's not
that we're trying to make a mockery
obvious but something true that we can
learn a lesson from and you know there
was a child that was marooned in the
flood times on a tree and as the water
was actually beneath him he could not
leave the tree at all and there was a
crocodile coming up trying to snap
toward him and he being taught in the
church all along you know about the Holy
Trinity so to speak his own
understanding of it he instead of
calling out in a way that perhaps would
have called to the creator himself he
said in his own little way that you know
you know Oh God I need your help I need
your help right now and you know what
don't send your son because this is not
child
now if you take a careful look at that
it definitely shows that the child did
not understand on one side or should I
say from one angle the child who did not
understand perhaps what the Christianity
has been teaching but from the nature of
the child you know the natural
inclination towards the one maker the
child is saying o you who made me you
alone come and help me don't send anyone
else I need you who created me you who
is in absolute control of this
particular situation of mine and that's
exactly what islam teaches that you know
you call out to the one who made you the
for answers and menu g boom opava yada
you know is there anyone beside he who
actually made you that would respond to
the distress in the time of distress
it is definitely allah alone you know
eleven mala is there any war deity with
Allah or any deity in partnership with
Allah meaning with your makers no he is
alone and this is what Islam is all
about so you truly if a person
surrenders to the one who made him or
her what would make him recognize that
this message is actually from the maker
himself is that the message would not
have in it the calling towards the
worship of the one who brought the
message but rather the owner of the
message so the same applies to say for
example what we term Imams or the sheiks
or even if you're a scholar you know I
happen to be a person who issues
religious decrease within my own society
and community and and still we never
ever allow people to worship us in any
way
if someone's committed a sin for example
islam teaches you that that is between
you and your maker there are two types
of sins one is that which you've you
serve the rights of a fellow human being
if that's the case you need to apologize
to them obviously but we're talking of
you know sins that are committed between
you and your maker you do not get
delivered by a priest or a person who is
an imam and so on
what definitely would happen is you
would cry out to your own maker in the
darkest corner or
nice to say oh my maker I have
transgressed against you I regret what
I've done I admit what I've done I am
sorry I will I asked your forgiveness
and I will not do it again we believe
that as soon as you say that genuinely
the sin is wiped out completely without
a doubt now some might teach that okay
you need to go through a church you need
to go through a crease you need to go
through a man we believe that no you go
through your maker and the maker is
known as a fool Raheem which means most
forgiving most merciful
also known as rahmanir rahim' which
means most merciful in a specific way
and most merciful in a general way
amazingly if you take a look at that it
shows that Islam is actually based on
true mercy and true forgiveness the
forgiveness of the one who made you and
you need to feel the link yourself you
and your maker that is the plug-in that
Islam is so unique about and
alhamdulillah I really believe that so
many people have turned to Islam one of
the prime reasons because I usually ask
people you know what was it that was so
beautiful about Islam that made you turn
to it and they always say I can actually
talk to my maker I don't need to confess
my sins to anyone I don't need to
confess sins to someone who might be
perhaps more sinful than I am and yet I
don't even know and I only find out
years later that this person has been
perhaps engaging in some you know
activity that we were not really we
wouldn't have believed and we were busy
asking them to forgive us and deliver us
and so on but with Islam it was always a
direct like in it was myself and my
maker and this is what was the beauty of
the Deen so we asked the Almighty Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala really to guide us
all and to show us I usually tell the
people that if you are looking for the
truth always pray for the purest
teachings of Jesus Christ may peace be
upon him you know ask to be guided to
the purest teachings of Jesus and by the
will of Allah you will be guided just to
the purest teachings of Jesus may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala help us all and
guide us all I mean you know I mean tell
us sheikh can you define before we get
into the next question the difference be
Queen when someone is judging you and
someone's trying to give the tender
loving advice to you because sometimes
people are very sensitive so when you
try to give them some good advice
they'll say stop judging me
so can you define the difference
something that I've come across being a
counselor who tries to help the youth
and so on that every time we try and
advise people they're quick to say stop
judging me but the difference I would
think is when someone says you are a bad
person that is a judgment that is a
statement that is passed but if someone
says my sister I think this is not a
good idea you know according to the Dean
this is wrong they are not saying you
are wrong but the action is wrong and a
lot of the times I'm quite careful to
try and I know we are human beings we
all do make mistakes I mean we must not
you know we need to get that quite clear
we're all human beings we all need help
myself included but I try my best and
I'm sure a lot of us do to separate the
action from the person who is engaging
in the action because you know the
almighty loves us all but the deed is
what is of essence the deed is what is
either good or bad so normally if a
person is just explaining to you that
the deeds are good or bad they are not
judging you but if a person tells you
that you are a good person or a bad
person they are actually judging you and
usually what would happen is we would
not mind a good judgment
nobody says you're judging me when you
say brother you're a good man you know
stop judging me but but normally when
you say something a little bit should I
say on the negative side then we quick
to hear the statements you know you're
judging me however I believe that we
need advice and all of us need advice
because the whole dean and spirituality
is based on sincere advice for one
another and what I do believe is that if
someone is advising you and they are
telling you what is right and wrong what
we are taught to do is to accept that as
advice and to try and understand it and
to work to inshallah put it into
practice by the will of Allah Subhanahu
WA Ta'ala but let's not say you're being
judgmental when really a judgement has
not been passed so if somebody is trying
to advise their Muslim brother or sister
to let when they see them
say taking 10-15 minutes a day or more
to put up makeup on but then when
they're calling them to salat or the
brother is blow drying his hair and
putting the hairspray and it's here and
it takes you know maybe as much as the
woman but he doesn't have time to make
the salat and now that person has got
his brother a sister to tune in and
they're hearing us trying to advise them
to salat is this out of the love that we
have for them this is no judgment
whatsoever in fact this is holding the
hand and trying to guide in a way that
we all would be appreciative of I would
really appreciate and I still do
appreciate those who correct me in a
beautiful way to remind me of my maker
and my duty unto my America because
definitely if a person is reminding us
of our duties unto our maker that is no
you know they're not just passing a
judgement against us and so on they are
merely telling us that you know you need
to be conscious of your link with Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
to give you a quick example sometimes
when I have told some people you know
let's go to the Masjid for Salah they
would quickly say well what do you think
we don't go and I've got a period to say
it's not like I think you don't go but I
think let's go now me you know I'm
telling it to you now
so so sometimes when you tell people you
know make sure that you eat halal they
say what do you think I'm eating Haram
as that is if the bet is a low statement
it's not like we think you eating Hara
we're just saying that you know what I
it's we would like you to just ensure
that what you do is right you must be
doing it right but we just want to
confirm and we want to encourage you so
it's more of an encouragement which is
actually superb
you know it reminds me of a person who's
an athlete who's constantly told by the
coach to do better and better it doesn't
mean they're not doing the best but
they're just being reminded to do better
in sharla beautiful beautiful
masha'Allah we're gonna take a break
Shaikh we right back with more and some
more questions on this topic with Mufti
Mac here on the Deen show don't go
anywhere
you when I embrace the slam from that
day on I knew I never wanted to drink
another drink in my life I never wanted
to smoke I never wanted to hurt my body
because I realized that it was a
blessing you know to be able to see life
from the perspective of Islam because
it's like a lens that clarifies life for
you and so I started seeing the clarity
of life and I said this is what I've
been looking for all my life now all I
have to do is live up to it back here on
the D show with our special guests all
the way from Zimbabwe and multi-bank
thank you again for being with us here
on the D show we're honored to have you
with us
hamdulillah we talked about in the
beginning the purity of Islam the call
to worship the maker of mankind the
Creator and have a direct connection and
Islam is based on proven evidence or
whoever wants to look into it they will
see it's a way of life that fits with
the human nature and we talked about the
young boy who did what what was in his
very nature he called on God alone not
the creation and now we differentiated
between the judging someone and giving
the lovely advice so we're gonna get
into a question here I'm gonna
paraphrase it and now that the viewing
audience knows that the difference
between the judging and the loving
advice hopefully would give some loving
advice to the person in question in the
question how's that she okay so the the
person now is asking about their
sister-in-law so sisters asking about a
sister sister-in-law how she's been
advising her for years now over 7-8
years about the modest dressed and
putting on the hijab and she's kind of
running to a dead end
and every time they get together she
doesn't try to bring it up but on
occasion she does and she hears such
excuses as she would be the first in her
community to do it she kind of you know
shuns it off but she had so much love
for her that now she thought okay
through the program we can get her to
watch it we can have someone who's on
such as yourself to advise her at the
same time she wanted to address the the
lead-up the protective gel
see the loving protective jealousy that
the husband should have also in regards
to his wife so it's a two-fold question
you know to be honest we need to be very
very patient when it comes to calling
people towards the goodness we never
lose hope even if it means we go on for
years on end but we need to constantly
you know tap inshallah in the right
places and say the right things ask a
lot of help and guidance pray for the
people that you're going to be calling
towards Allah because it is Allah who
will actually turn them not you you know
I can say whatever I want but my words
would not be effective if Allah does not
want them to be effective so I need to
pray to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
to ask him to make the words that I'm
saying be digested in a beautiful way so
that the person can turn towards Allah
so that's point number one we pray for
the sister may Allah make it easy for
her
secondly the sister you need to know
that at some stage you know you have to
be strong even if you're going to be the
first person in your whole community in
fact if I would look at that as a bonus
because anyone who emulates your example
after that even after you passed away
you would be getting the full reward
because you started that good Sunnah in
your own community so although you might
get a little bit of you know flak in the
sense of dirty eyes or sometimes dirty
words that's all part of the test that
Allah promises he says you know when you
do that which is correct and you you're
doing it because of your Eman and your
belief in me meaning in allah subhanahu
wa ala then I will test you just to
confirm that you're being genuine so if
you did it for Allah you will remain but
if you did it for people then you will
abstain as soon as they have a comment
and you won't have an answer you won't
know how to face but we need to be
worried about the day we face with allah
subhanahu wata'ala so my sister be
strong and remember that allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has kept our days in this
world quite limited and at the same time
we'd like to enjoy this world and we
want to enjoy it in a way that we will
be heading straight through even in the
life after death to the same enjoyment
in
much much better by the help of allah
subhanahu wata'ala
so i hope and i pray that you can become
a little bit stronger and inshallah a
means of guidance even for others i know
of some sisters who are very very
influential the day they turn to hijab
they were they lost a little bit of
their popularity but at the same time
there are hundreds of thousands of
others will follow the examples
depending on how popular they were I'm
sure these people would earn paradise
just who that particular multiplication
of the reward by the mercy of allah
subhanahu wata'ala because he promises
that to us so if i had the opportunity
to actually be the first in my community
to to do something that would please
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala that is actually
a duty that I've been week so far to
fulfill I would really jump to it to say
may Allah write my name down as being
the first person who started this in my
society and community because it's
something great that having been said we
get to the husband's and what is known
as the Veera some people call it
possessiveness you know it's the healthy
possessiveness when you're very
possessive over what is yours so if for
example a woman displays all the beauty
that she has and every other woman
displays all the beauty that they have
you will always find by default someone
who is prettier perhaps they have a
bitter and I'm going to say as it is
perhaps they have better legs to have
the perhaps they have better hair
perhaps they have a better complexion
better skin there will always be someone
who has something better and if you are
the person who has the best in your
community there will come a time when
you develop wrinkles and when whatever
you have had there will be someone
younger than you who then all the eyes
turn towards so only slam does is Islam
says hang on we wanted you to appreciate
and we want you to respect and we want
you to elevate the status of those whom
you have loved at one stage in your life
is it needs to be built it must not just
be based on something external it is
based on their goodness of the heart
like we are taught at deen-ul-haq which
means the consciousness of the Almighty
and the character and conduct if someone
has brilliant character they dedicated
their ready to sacrifice the love of
such a person
even the day they might put an extra
pound or two on it will be even more by
the will of Allah I always tell well let
me not say exactly who I say to my wife
I always say to her if you know what
some kind of life you put on an extra
pound I've got more to love love what
come on and that's just a way to say you
know that look it's not obviously women
are all concerned about about their
weight and so on and I'm sure the men
are too but sometimes you know you
helplessly your metabolism rate
decreases and as you grow older you
might put on a pound or two it is up to
the man or up to the spouse to ensure
that he makes it clear that look as much
as we would like ourselves to be healthy
but we are taught that if I would not
you would not lose my love just because
of a pound or two you put perhaps like I
said you would have more to love in
terms of weight and in terms of size
come by the will of allah subhanahu
wata'ala that having been said it is
important for us to encourage our
spouses I know of a lot of brothers
sadly who tell their wives you know what
I don't want you to dress in this way
and that is like reverse oppression you
know a lot of the people in the Western
world think that the Muslims are
oppressed wear the hijab I have come
across thousands of cases of women who
want to wear the hijab but their
families or their men are telling them
not to enforcing them not to so that is
the reverse hijab which a lot of people
don't ever speak about sorry the reverse
oppression what people do not speak
about and this is something we need to
highlight so my brother it is your duty
to encourage your spouse and and those
who are perhaps under your authority or
under let's say your guardianship is to
encourage them in the right direction in
a beautiful gentle way to say that you
know what this is the responsibility you
have to Allah and I like to always speak
about the pros and cons when it comes to
that which is easily understood by the
mind like I said sometimes revelation
for those whose Eman is weak
might not have that impact yet although
it does have some form of an impact even
for the disbelievers but at the same
time if you have a logical answer they
would definitely understand it and they
would definitely come to appreciate the
goodness of the hijab and the goodness
of the dress code and there is so much
that comes with
like I always say it's a whole package
so if you have part of the package in
China you'll enjoy the rest of the perks
of it but if you decide you don't want
you know a part of it then you might
that there might be a little pay Ament
that you will have to actually top up
with let's hope that that's not going to
be a little bit expensive for you
obviously I would it is just in an
example for but I hope and I pray can
understand that the duties that we have
onto a lhasa so if we transgress the
commands of allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala if
we go against what allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala has asked us then definitely
we would be the ones that lost it's not
him who would actually be at a loss so
we need to consider this and we need to
really make an effort to please allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala the hadith makes it
quite clear muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam says whoever displeases Allah
because they want to please people they
they would earn the displeasure of Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala and soon the
displeasure of the people as well and
whoever would like to whoever pleases
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala
and in the process finds people are
displeased with that they definitely
would earn the pleasure of Allah and
soon the people would realize and
understand and they would also be
pleased at some stage we ask Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala to strengthen us and
to help us all and to help us to help
one another as well I mean saying thank
you so much for finding the time to be
with us inshallah God willing we can
have you back again sometime in the
future how's that sound
inshallah why not definitely al
hamdulillah this was my first session
obviously here and it's been a good
experience and I hope and I pray that
perhaps we can have a bit more of this
inshaallah sounds good thank you so much
jazakallah Haider we started with peace
we end with peace peace be with you
Salaam alaikum Robert along with you a
little later
and that was our special guest all the
way from Zimbabwe mufti bank sheikh
thank you very much for being with us
here and the deanship lee said our
saloons to all the whole community out
there from myself and from the deso team
to all of you peace be with you Salaam
alaikum and to all the viewing audience
I hope that you got to benefit now is
just common
design indicates a designer and this
whole universe didn't come by chance
so the foolish thing that you see out
there on the Billboard that we talked
about just foolishness you see this is
like probably so just to create some
doubt but there is no doubt it's beyond
a shadow of a doubt that there is a
creator for this creation the birds and
the bees and the seven seas and
everything that you see around us but
people want to go away from the
responsibility that we have as human
beings which is to obey our Creator who
created us you have a boss at work
that's right that boss needs to be
obeyed but now if you fess up and you're
like yeah okay I give in yeah there is a
crater just common sense right you quit
blocking it then you're gonna have to do
the next thing you have to be sincerely
submitting to him and as it's nom then
we talked about the purity of Islam of
just dialing up direct there's no
middlemen in it's now just like that
young boy in the Sheikh story nobody
else did he call upon it was in his
nature like a little three four or five
year old kid it's in our nature that we
just call upon our maker the one who
created us and that is what the
foundation of the message that all the
messengers brought and taught they
called us to call on the one who created
Jesus Moses Abraham and all these
messengers that were sent throughout
time bringing the purpose of life to us
calling us to have a relationship with
our Creator because otherwise the
opposite happens if you don't have a
relationship with your Creator then what
happens most of the time you end up
turning to loving the things of the
world and you become spiritually void so
you start to really love money to a
level that you just can't live without
it and then if you have a billion and
you lose half of that you just go
suicidal or for instance you just into
cars and and women women into just
pleasing the man and then it's just a a
connection with the temporal the
temporary the transitory things of this
world but when your heart is attached to
his maker then that's when you really
get that satisfaction that peace that
contentment that money can't buy so we
talked about that so it's really
important that you
call upon your craters that young boy
did in the shake story called on God
alone ask God to guide you it's not
blocking the truth and the advice that
we had for our sister oh man just do it
just just do it just do it ain't nothing
to it but to do it that's all I can say
because at the end now when you're six
feet under and then just contemplate
when you're all alone nobody's around
you think when you die hmm you get
scared when you're going down an alley
and it's all pitch black you're in the
room by yourself it just lights are off
and nobody's around and you hear like
you know some squeaking and you freak
out imagine you're in the grave now you
want the pleasure of your crater and now
you've lived to hold your whole life
disobeying him and people sent you to
sign this another sign right here
so think about it is it worth it and all
those people that you were worried about
you were displeased in him because of
the popularity you know you wanted to
fit in so now it's like forget about
what my craters tell me to do I'm just
gonna follow John dick Sally and Susie
no don't do it just do it
and everything that the greatest told us
to do is it's beneficial for us it's
good it's good and you benefit from it
it's for your protection it's to help
you become the best so let's do it right
now before we're in the grave before
death comes because at the end is too
late then you're gonna wish you can go
back but you're not gonna have a second
chance so now is the chance you're
watching this just do it just do it
ain't nothing to it but to do it do the
good things that a lot of the critters
told us to do tune in every week follow
us on the Twitter keep up with our shows
Facebook like us there help us get this
message out to the world so more people
can learn about the purpose of life they
can live it and they can be happy they
can truly be happy we'll see you next
time
inshallah God willing until then peace
be with you